Sin embargo, la paz tanto en el ámbito macro como micro es necesaria
para lograr una paz sostenible,
y las organizaciones no gubernamentales locales,
las autoridades locales y los representantes de la sociedad civil
deberían ser los principales protagonistas del proceso de abajo arriba.
Luego, por supuesto, hay obstáculos.
Los protagonistas locales a menudo no tienen ni el capital
y a veces tampoco la logística ni la capacidad técnica
para desarrollar programas de pacificación de manera eficaz.
Los actores internacionales deben ampliar la financiación y el apoyo
para la resolución de conflictos locales.
En cuanto al Congo, ¿qué se puede hacer?
Después de dos décadas de conflicto y millones de muertos,
está claro que tenemos que cambiar nuestro enfoque.
Basándome en mi investigación de campo,
creo que los actores internacionales y congoleños
deberían prestar más atención a la resolución de conflictos por la tierra
y a la promoción de la reconciliación intercomunitaria.
Por ejemplo, en la provincia de los kivu,
el Instituto Vida y Paz y sus socios congoleños
crearon foros intercomunitarios
para discutir los detalles del conflicto por la tierra,
y en estos foros se han encontrado soluciones
para ayudar a controlar la violencia.
Se necesita urgentemente este tipo de programas
en todo el este de Congo.
Es con programas como estos
que podemos ayudar a la gente como Isabelle y su marido.
No son varitas mágicas,
sino que tienen en cuenta
las causas profundamente arraigadas de la violencia
y podrían ser definitivamente un punto de inflexión.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)